downright apocalyptic images coming out
of Australia right now there are now six
fires burning at emergency levels smoke
is so intense and so thick it can be
seen from space 2,000 homes have been
destroyed six million hectares of land
charge a staggering toll on the nation's
wildlife these record-breaking bush
fires in Australia have been kicked off
by things like lightning strikes a few
cases of arson and winds but one of the
biggest reasons they become so extreme
is the same reason that East Africa is
flooding bush fires in Australia are a
natural part of the country's ecosystem
their fire season varies across regions
even New South Wales the most populous
state is used to blazes breaking out in
1974 fires burned 3.5 million Hector's
and in 2003 another two million Hector's
were lost to fire but the fires that
started in 2019 are even worse 4.9
million hectares and New South Wales
have burned already and it's only going
to grow so why is this fire season so
awful
for starters as the world is getting
warmer from climate change
so is Australia 2019 was its hottest
year on record with parts of the country
reaching 45 degrees Celsius in December
2019 was also its driest the places here
in gray have seen historic droughts
together that provides the perfect
conditions for bush fires to start and
spread quickly throughout the year other
large-scale climate drivers affect
Australia's weather and its likeliness
to burn but one of the most influential
is the Indian Ocean dipole or the IOD
the IOD is a big temperature gradient
that affects a surface water in the
Indian Ocean from the edge of Africa to
the edge of Australia meteorologists
been measuring these temperature shifts
for decades in three phases positive
neutral and negative when the IOD is
neutral the surface water in the Indian
Ocean is evenly warm a negative phase is
when the winds come from the west and
shift the warm water towards Australia
warmer water means more evaporation
which means more rain so Australia gets
more rain than usual
sometimes even floods but the colder
water near East Africa means they get
less rain and even droughts a positive
phase is what's happening now it's when
the winds come in from the east and
shift the warm water towards Africa
which causes flooding there and droughts
in Australia the entire process of
shifting water temperatures is natural
but 2019 s was extreme the positive IOT
was one of the strongest on record with
the water temperature difference between
Africa and Australia being unusually
high
hence extreme weather in Australia but
also in Africa the worst flooding in two
decades more than three times their
annual rainfall in only four days
scientists believe it's linked to record
temperatures in the Indian Ocean the
good news is the IOD is already shifting
to neutral which should bring some
much-needed relief to Australia in
Africa in early 2020 but as the planet
continues to warm some scientists are
concerned about how that might affect
weather phenomenons like the IOD one
study predicts positive IO DS like what
we're seeing now could happen more
frequently as global temperatures rise
and warm the Indian Ocean combine that
with the rising overall temperature of
Australia and these kinds of devastating
fires fueled by unusually dry vegetation
could become the new normal
[Music]
you
[Music]